Ritsuka It's
been a long time, but did you find your feelings? I haven't decided.
[Music]
I had a bath
Good night
[Music]
Ah,
I said something strange Oh, no, I only have one bed, and I live
alone.
You don't have to go that far, but if you can't afford to live in a house with hardships, there's a park or
something to talk about, but
what's wrong with you
?  Attan
[music]
Let me show you Dandy Does
the God of Wisdom charge a consultation fee?
Mr.
Where are you now? There must be
a special lecture you wanted to attend at the university at this time today.
You're in the hospital right now,
so the request must have something to do with Rika-san, so I don't
mind if I'm a little aggressive, but
don't worry, I won't make a request as difficult as
the.  Please
give me the duplicate key to the room Don't be unreasonable What's wrong with giving her the duplicate key to the room
?
I
've found a good clan sutra, I'll
put it here I
'll give you a duplicate key,
so please consult with me  That's not right